salud en directo América de France 24
mar Romero sala con nosotros en el
estudio mar Gracias como siempre por
estar siempre lista para hablar de temas
de salud y más hoy cuando nosotros
último programa antes de salir de una
pausa por la fiesta de diciembre y
cerramos el año 2022 con un balance mar
las cosas buenas pero también las malas
empecemos primero con las malas Buenos
días Raúl si es momento de mirar hacia
atrás ver cómo ha sido este 2022 y dejar
esos puntos claros prepararnos también
para lo que venga sin duda una de las
noticias del año ha sido la expansión de
la viruela del mono rebautizada por la
OMS como empox en vez de Monkey pocks
una enfermedad que existe desde hace
décadas pero que en este 2022 ha llegado
a países que antes no la conocían fuera
de esos países donde la enfermedad solía
ser endémica y además aparte de la mala
noticia que es tener un virus nuevo
circulando nos puso un espejo delante y
nos mostró muchas cosas que seguimos
haciendo mal como mundo no como
respuesta global las enfermedades hoy en
día para empezar el estigma o el
desinterés que genera lo que sucede en
el continente africano no una enfermedad
que es conocida que circula desde hace
tiempo en ese continente que muchos
científicos habían advertido que tenía
el potencial de salir al resto del mundo
y afectarnos de esta forma pero pues que
nunca se invirtió para saber cómo se
podía combatir que podía suceder Cómo se
podían reformular las vacunas no porque
al final las prioridades en la
investigación no siempre la dicta al
final el interés público también el
estigma a la población lgbti nos
referimos especialmente a los hombres
gays y sexuales que han sido de los más
afectados fuera de los países endémicos
y volvimos a repetir por ejemplo esos
patrones que vimos con lo que pasó con
el VIH no que se hablaba de que esta
enfermedad afectaba a esta población más
para estigmatizar que para proteger
realmente o para asegurarnos del
bienestar de todo el mundo y por último
la rapidez relativa de las vacunas en
llegar a lugares como Estados Unidos o
Europa no cuando los países endémicos ni
siquiera tienen acceso a los
tratamientos para mí eso serían los tres
puntos principales terminamos repasando
un poco las cifras sabemos que han
disminuido por suerte ya no estamos en
esas mismas situación de alarma pero no
ha desaparecido por ejemplo en la región
de las Américas vemos que hay incluso
algunos países en los que el cambio
semanal No desde la semana pasada a la
semana actual han crecido los casos
estamos hablando por ejemplo de Estados
Unidos Brasil Chile y Argentina también
otros por suerte ha disminuido pero el
peligro de que este virus quede
circulando sigue presente bueno ahora sí
vamos con lo que me gusta una de las
buenas noticias y las vacunas bivalentes
contra el covid 19 y sus variantes Así
es vamos a hacer una década así así
estamos exactamente por supuesto para
muchos de 2022 ha sido el año en que
parece que el cobi 19 después de la ola
de ómicron ha desaparecido recordemos
Igualmente que solo esta semana han
habido tres millones de contagios en
todo el mundo que no es una cifra baja
por suerte las vacunas que se han podido
desarrollar por ejemplo farmacéuticas
como de pfizer biontech y de moderna
pudieron adaptar las vacunas originales
hechas contra el covid 19 y contra esa
variante original del virus para las
variantes circulando Como por ejemplo
algunas de las variantes de omicron que
sigue siendo la variante dominante hoy
en día han ido cambiando algunas de esas
sub variantes pero digamos que estamos
todavía en la familia omicron algo que
por cierto también es una buena noticia
que no haya parecido todavía otra nueva
variante que pueda escapar la inmunidad
de la misma forma que lo había hecho
esta en septiembre se dio la luz verde a
este tipo de vacunas en la Unión Europea
escuchémoslo
dos vacunas nuevas seguras y efectivas
se han añadido a la lista de vacunas
disponibles en la Unión Europea estas
vacunas adaptadas están diseñadas para
mostrarle a nuestro sistema inmune
distintas variantes del virus del covid
19 para expandir nuestra respuesta
inmune especialmente hacia las variantes
que circulan recientemente
otra de las noticias sanitarias que
marcaba este año sin duda los brotes de
cólera alrededor del mundo una mala
noticia mar y una de las más dolorosas
que se extiende desde el Caribe
latinoamericano hasta medio oriente por
ejemplo en el Líbano no vemos Que hay
muchos países que se han visto afectados
por este brote recordemos el cólera es
una enfermedad que llega con las
desgracias por ejemplo con las
inundaciones en Pakistán o con los
desplazamientos forzosos siempre tiene
que ver con la falta de acceso a
sistemas de saneamiento o agua potable
no Además es una enfermedad que es
fácilmente tratable que tiene vacuna
pero que se ha debido racionar la vacuna
en dar una dosis en vez de las dos dosis
que está recomendado
precisamente porque hay una escasez
desde el Líbano uno de los lugares donde
pues se ha visto afectado este brote en
los campos de refugiados llegaba este
testimonio
no podemos permitirnos comprar agua
embotellada por nuestra situación
financiera cómo lo voy a pagar Tengo
seis hijos cada día necesito al menos
cinco galones de agua donde consigo
dinero para eso debemos agua de los
tanques sabemos que no deberíamos pero
no tenemos opción
bueno mar y para terminar más optimistas
no esta última Crónica de salud De este
2022 otro de los hallazgos del año la
secuencia completa del genoma humano la
noticia que llegó en abril de este año y
que personalmente fue de las que más
me emocionó hasta este momento se tenía
solo secuenciado el 92% del ADN humano
se logró este último 8% ahí se
identificaron 2.000 genes codificantes
en ellos dos millones de variantes
genéticas decir que cosas que de persona
a persona de estos dos mil genes 100
activos es decir que pueden codificar
proteínas que luego se convierten eso en
características pues físicas de nuestro
cuerpo de nuestra forma de funcionar
recordemos esta secuencias como tener el
índice de una gran enciclopedia que
todavía hace falta leer y además es
especialmente importante este último 8%
era particularmente difícil porque había
muchas secuencias repetidas pero se cree
que allí en esos cromosomas que se han
ido revelando en esas partes hay algunos
de los secretos que podrían ayudarnos en
el futuro a entender mejor por ejemplo
Cómo se forman los óvulos o los
espermatozoides del proceso evolutivo
también de la especie humana y en
algunas otras partes de los cromosomas
en las puntas en este caso cosas que
tienen que ver por ejemplo con el
envejecimiento o incluso con los
secretos genéticos del cáncer mar
Muchísimas gracias como siempre por toda
la información y pues hasta el próximo
año 2023 un abrazo en 2023 Así es mar y
felices fiestas como siempre Un gusto
compartir con